[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine partielle nicht ich
war auf der esm 2009 10 das ist die
größte süßwarenmesse der welt und ich
habe dort ordentlich zugeschlagen hier
seht ihr meine ausbeute
das ist fast alles für euch denn ich
werde jetzt mal schauen was in den tüten
so drinnen steckt was sich dann daraus
zubereiten kann
und jetzt werden wir gemeinsam einen
cache cache machen also eine süßigkeiten
torte morath darf die dann später
probieren und ich bin selber mal
gespannt was ihr entsteht bei fieber
konnte ich ja die hopi schokolade für
euch ergattern
die vierte schokoladensorte neben weißer
vollmilch und zartbitter schokolade
danke claudia danke andreas wird lecker
und schön so ich ja mal die tüte von
philipp dahm auf den fidschis auf die
torte weil die schön bunt sind
bei lenker war mir beim scannen und
davos richtig gesunde zutaten eingepackt
also nicht nur ungesund süßigkeiten
[Musik]
bei momo waren wir beim lieben andreas
und da nehme ich jetzt die momo creme
das ist der brotaufstrich endlich vom
boxen zu machen dann haben wir hier
küchle bei küchen nehmen wir auf jeden
fall sonderbar
vielleicht macht blumen mit mehr sonne
war vielleicht etwas am hut
ich habe eine große tüte von rüdiger von
deco back da haben wir bitter mantel
aroma das nehmen wir auf jeden fall back
trend spray jetzt sage ich euch in der
tüte den bug transport habe ich in
meiner schublade
[Musik]
und von der liebe nadja habe ich auf der
messe den rennkalender für kids bekommen
und den efta länder für erwachsene da
ist leckere schokolade drin mit einer
dattel in der mitte und da werde ich auf
jeden fall die schokolade von ihr
benutzten die gibt es einmal in weiß
dann mit rose mit himbeere in vollmilch
und zartbitter und die schokolade die
ist echt gut die ist zertifiziert ist es
eine hand und koschere schokolade und
die nadja achtet einfach darauf dass die
kakaobauern auf jeden fall genug geld
bekommen dass die schokolade gut und
nachhaltig hergestellt wird
hier haben wir war wie aus der pfalz
kreis kennt ihr und stehen gibt es auch
in der kleine ausführung und dann fällt
mir ein kommt noch der hobby ins spiel
mit seinem kanton und martini ich glaub
die krieg das womit rein krümmel und
dann haben einen schönen krampe boden
ich habe mir vorgestellt wenn es einen
candy cache werden soll müssen da bilden
rein die schön saftig sind dann die
creme und oben drauf machen wir dann auf
jeden fall mit der ruby schokolade die
kann ich ja schön ein schmelzen sondern
klausur trüber und dann ganz viele
kennedys obendrauf so weiter hat
überlegt aber das machen wir jetzt
einfach unermesslich das schön ab und
dann könnt ihr die torte auch gut
nachmachen also ich hab mir jetzt
gedacht entweder nehmen weil jetzt die
toffees oder diese creme aber ich glaube
ich nehme die creme als zuckerersatz
braucht dieses der kartoffelsalat fürs
mittagessen vier eier
neben hat diese creme in der hoffnung
dass sie sich löst aber es sieht doch
gut aus also mit butter wird sie sich
auf jeden fall lösen zu nehmen jetzt 200
gramm
prise salz und vanilla extrakt das habe
ich ja immer im spiel und dann schön
schaumig verrühren und dann kann ich
schon mal öl abmessen zu nehmen wir dann
auch 200 gramm und vielleicht habe ich
buttermilch oder mit stalin war auch 200
das habe ich noch 200 nähe und nehmen
jetzt dass mandl mail auf gott ich habe
das auf der er selber gar nicht geöffnet
das riecht richtig lecker gerüstet doch
dann nehmen wir jetzt 100 gramm und da
noch backpulver rein und dann haben wir
schon die basis vielleicht immer noch
mit der man reinmachen drei tropfen
bittermandel aroma und backpulver dann
nämlich zwei zähler
dass flüssigkeiten immer gar nicht den
milliliter ab sondern in gramm finde ich
einfach und genau 200 gramm und 200 km
[Musik]
vielleicht seine masse von stücke noch
in den teig rein
das mache ich noch
100 gramm acea mit amaretto geschmack
schließlich noch ein bisschen älter
tychy sich jetzt hier die flüssigkeiten
rhein bei niedriger stufe dann marzipan
fein reiben und die trockenen zutaten
dazu 7
ich glaub das wird ein richtig leckerer
mandl marzipan teigmasse bahn lässt sich
ganz einfach reiben wenn man es vorher
kurz ins gefrierfach stellt aber ich
mache das jetzt einfach direkt so dass
die trockenen zutaten 7 und dann kurz
einrühren
[Musik]
alles einrühren und dann müsste der teig
fertig sein
normalerweise
schade dass ich ein drinnen seitiges roh
gegessen
na ja und jetzt schön in die back ringe
einführen ihr könnt es entweder auf zwei
paar klinge aufteilen oder direkt auf 4
dann bugs nämlich schneller
so mache ich das jetzt 20 cm durchmesser
damit ich eine schöne hohe trotte
hinbekomme
viele kennen die torte ich muss schon
hoch sein dass verteidigt den teig
vorsichtig und gleichmäßig also riechen
und schmecken tut doch schon mal gut
der kommt jetzt hier in den backofen der
andere in den anderen aber heißluft wird
auch gehen da hätte ich einen unten nach
oben backen können und während der
bauzeit kann ich schon mal die krähen
zubereiten wird die creme habe ich jetzt
hier 200 gramm sahne
die lasse ich jetzt hier kurz aufkochen
und dann mache ich wie so eine art ghana
kommt da nämlich die schokolade rein
aber ich probiere jetzt mal das ist
jetzt schokolade verfeinert mit
rosenblättern service pack 1 guckt mal
das sind die rosenblütenblätter dies zu
besonders die werden vielleicht für
obendrauf noch benutzen ich nehme jetzt
hier einfach noch die weiße schokolade
die wird verkleinert davon nämlich 100
gramm und sobald die sahne aufgekocht
ist sich die vom herd herunter fröde
schokolade ein
und dann kommt das ganze in den
kühlschrank und muss richtig richtig
kalt werden bevor ich später dann die
creme aufschlagen kann
jetzt kommt noch der crunch boden und
dafür nämlich selbst ich ein schoko
reiße ich glaube die ganze packung
brauche ich nicht unterzugehen
man sieht ja jetzt schon die große
fläche die hälfte also 100 gramm
ich darf ihnen dich selber sehr gut das
ist eine zwei einheimischen kurator ist
und nicht voll milch gibt es auch in
freue mich natürlich aber ich bin ja
sonst aber es ist hälfte das sind 100
gramm und das jetzt hier über dem warmen
wasserbad schmelzen und da kann ich dann
noch ein paar amaretto näselt reinmacht
dann passt es nämlich zum teil
und ich habe noch einen schönen trans
mit dabei sind sie selbst gebacken aus
guckt mal so schön nicht so perfekt wie
ist das so wie die anderen gekauft
die sehen einfach selbst gemacht aus das
finde ich schön der gedanke der moment
wenn du die ameria teenies liebe also
möchtest standorten zu packen und
einfach nur ganz wenige ich nehme nur 40
gramm was schmerz messen haben in diesem
so schön knusprig die zerbröselt dann so
jetzt ist die schokolade schön
geschmolzen kommt mir die mariachi kekse
mit rein
spacex
[Musik]
und dann einfach schön verteilt und am
besten mit einer burger presse oder mit
einem glas flach drücken
und dann stelle ich den tortenboden auf
kühle und dann später die torte schön
zusammen sitzen
[Musik]
sind schon so gespannt auf die torte
jetzt mache ich die creme und dafür
nehme ich jetzt einmal die schoko sahne
die ist richtig schön kalt da musst du
echt ganz darauf aufpassen ansonsten
kann es nämlich passieren dass sie euch
einfach gewinnt beim aufschlagen
was sollte ich die schoko sahne gibst
dich hier nochmal zu neutralen sahne
dazu damit sie ein bisschen leichter
wird gebe ich noch quark rein
ich werde ich das dein handicap drückt
also bisschen quark noch ein bisschen
gefragt ja immer wie entwickelst du
deine rezepte das mache ich einfach so
und oft überlege ich hatte schon im
vorfeld wieviel menge wie viel von allem
und so weiter immer weiter ungefähr bei
rot zeigen wie viel ein bisschen zucker
wie viel butter oder fett und bei krems
ist es eben genau so und dann schmecke
ich es ab und meistens schmeckt
entstanden
hoffentlich so damit noch ein bisschen
feiner wird etwas limetten abrieb darauf
achten dass die limette unbehandelt ist
so dass man die schale mit verzehren
kann einfach nur so ein kleines bisschen
[Musik]
dann etwas zitronensaft limettensaft das
selbst sauber wenn ich das machen könnte
was eine limette eine zitrone und dann
gebe ich da das erdbeer seiner partner
zu dann habe ich nämlich richtig schönen
erdbeergeschmack und da ist sogar
richtige set markt drin
das riecht man jetzt ganz vorsichtig
erstmal verrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt das etwa sommerbad einfach
einrühren
und stammen die cremes schlagen
die krimis fertig kann ich kurze
tortenböden hohl und dann können wir
schon die torte zusammensetzen
hier sitzt der feste kramp boden
der sieht echt gut aus und ich nehme
jetzt zum zusammenkleben der böden
einfach ein bisschen monat
da nehme ich gern die bonne maman die
schmeckt nämlich richtig gut das sind
auch verschiedene erdbeersorten drin
das schmeckt man davon einfach ein klein
wenig was auf den boden
so bekomme ich noch mal eine fruchtige
note mit rheine leichte säure das ist
lecker dann den ersten tortenboden drauf
da ist jetzt etwas schief gebacken den
schneide ich jetzt noch ganz kurz gerade
weg
[Musik]
ich setze ich hier einen sauberen
tortenring aus herum
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen was von der
leckeren erdbeer creme rein dann schön
verstreichen
es folgen die sommerlichen kennen die
torte
dann bestreite ich die tortenböden auf
der rückseite mit der marmelade und
setzte dann mit der marmelade nach unten
hier rein und fühle dann so die gesamte
flotte
[Musik]
heute morgen hätte ich nicht gedacht
dass es heute erdbeertorte wird aber das
wird nach der torte jetzt mache ich
einfach noch so viele creme rhein bis
hier oben alles schön glatt
abgeschlossen ist und dann kommt die
torte so glatt wie sie ist gleich in den
kühlschrank für etwa zwei stunden drei
oder vier wären besser aber ich stelle
sie einfach ganz kurz ins gefrierfach
so kann sie schon mal ein bisschen kalt
werden und dann reichen normalerweise
auf zwei stehen
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir zum highlight der
tochter nämlich zur deko dafür nehme ich
jetzt die ruby schokolade und schnell
für sie nun bei der schokolade ist
eigentlich nur wichtig zu beachten dass
sie nicht zu warm wird das heißt sowie
weiße schokolade nicht über das kochende
wasser parat sondern einfach nur über
das warme wasser bat gericht echt schön
für lecker fruchtig und ich denke sie
passt ganz gut zu der app tatorte
[Musik]
es ist nämlich auch das macht die hausse
an den rand tatort
[Musik]
mal gucken ob es klappt aber ich glaube
schon jetzt einfach die kombos und trieb
sich hier an den rand der tat
[Musik]
er ist relativ planlos was machen wir
aber jetzt nämlich erst einmal die ruby
schokolade und guck mal die retter ihre
farbe das ist ja keine zugesetzte farbe
und kein zugesetzter geschmack das ist
wirklich reine schokolade und die
kakaobohne die wirtin in einem
speziellen verfahren geerntet und dann
kommt einfach ein bisschen zitronensäure
rein und dann bleibt eben diese rosa
farbe
die spreng gleich jetzt hier so ein
bisschen drüber
ich wollte den trip machen
doch kein trip fehlt mir jetzt ein die
schokolade riecht nach erdbeere meinte
rosa ist wenn die recht leicht fruchtig
durch die erdbeer creme passt sehr gut
sehr sehr gut
[Musik]
nämlich noch die pink herzchen und
getragen und die finde ich cool weil die
echt ganz dünn sind guck mal nicht so
eine harte zuckermasse sondern einfach
richtig schönes dünnes herz konfetti ich
mache das ist die schokolade den bremer
ich hätte gerne
[Musik]
als ich will nur sagen das war eine
challenge denn die challenge war alles
wie es waren dich auf der messe gefunden
habe in die torte irgendwie mir rein zu
bringen
sie müssen weniger machen würde und dann
möchte schmetterling sein auch wenn die
gleiche dicke vielleicht war es ja ja
ich war ja mein bundes nächste
städtischen alpakas sind darunter die
spucke aber einen anspruch auf gemüse
die sind wolle aufgeladen ja gott oh
mein gott hast du schon mal auf eine
schule gehst du bist nicht mit dem so
kann aber bei uns ist aber gehört eine
weile das nächste stück muss ich
fotografieren erstklassig teils mit alex
stoppen kann ruhig 1 alleine ist ich
will heim sind laut alexa auch ein
halbes ich will nur mein gott wer ist
denn alles starken schülergruppen das
meint dass auch teile
wir brauchen diese macht das tut mir
wirklich entschuldigen es tut mir
wirklich leid ich habe erst gedacht dass
erwachsene menschen und puppen hatte
schon jetzt das auch probieren etwas
wagen
[Musik]
ja was machen was machte die mutter ein
braunes sakko
[Musik]
was macht so was macht blau weiß ich hab
euch grund wird damit ihr den kuchen
probiert jetzt steht er da um ruhezeiten
der heimischen eure nespresso porsche
school
natürlich habe ich gedacht was
verglichen so zu süß ist gut so hammer
also der boden der es mit diesen
reiswaffeln gemacht habe ich noch kein
martinis rhein-sieg rehm ist mit weißer
schokolade von der mafia und mit etwas
sonderbar und der boden des tanzes ich
habe den verein auch probiert den habe
ich ja mit dem mandelmilch macht und mit
der karamell creme wollen wir stehen mit
max frisch war dass ich war so genannten
was bist du halt nur das stimmt habe ich
meinen klammeraffe und die airline
klammer abwehrte
die fertig haben mich ganz schön wie
gehen wir in die werkstatt war schlecht
also ich mach die fotos und dann können
dort die ganze torte haben und euren
mädchen kindergeburtstag freiheit aber
nehmer ohne spaß ich find das ist schon
so eine richtig coole kinder
geburtstagstorte einfach nicht so süß
die creme schmeckt lecker und dann die
deko oben drauf und haben super halbe
schlägt wie und wie vielen dank an die
hersteller und an alle freunde auf der
messe und jetzt kommt noch das
gewinnspiel läuft ja jetzt hast du die
chance eine von neuen süßigkeiten
paketen zu gewinnen schreibt einfach
dafür den namen der firma also die dann
gleich darunter steht in die kommentare
unten und verlost dann das ganze unter
euch wenn du das paket von barbie mit
dem schokoladen reis gewinnen willst
dann schreib einfach war wie in die
kommentare
willst du das paket von küche gewinnen
dann schreib einfach küche für den
ramadan kalender und den efta länder und
die leckere schokolade einfach nur efta
länder möchte lieber cantuccini und
amore teenie probieren dann schreib
einfach belly cantuccini wenn du die
karamell creme und die karamellbonbons
von den muss probieren möchtest dann
einfach in die kommentare
wenn du das paket vom alpakas wenn
gewinnen möchte ist mit dem mandl mail
mandelöl und den weiteren zutaten dann
schreib einfach lemke für das bunte
paket von hitler mit den hippies den
ufos und den leckeren marshmallows
einfach in die kommentare
willst du die innovation mit der ruby
schokolade probieren dann schreib
einfach heilemann bei fieber und wenn du
einpacken junkie bis dann schreib
einfach d kino in die kommentare dann
bekommst du die verschiedenen aromen und
die weiteren tollen zutaten viel glück
beim gewinnspiel
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
es musste
bis laufen in die kamera winken so frank
kein wasser kocht wie kommst du jetzt an
dein wasser halte ich mich gelegt dass
die große kamera noch läuft das laster
bitte drin wenn du bist wie du
schneidest frank damaskus bitten